Simon why in the past few years has
quantum computing gotten so much
attention right well quantum computing
is something that academics have been
working on now for decades but what's
exciting is that it's all starting to
work in the sense that what we now have
in labs is getting to the regime where
it can actually do stuff that we can't
do by other means so it's you know it's
got that feeling that it's all about to
happen that said you never know how far
it is from where you are to when you've
actually got a working machine until
you've actually got the working machine
but we're all feeling very excited in
the field we're excited as well but then
also people outside the field companies
people who look for disruptive changes
in technology are obviously receptive to
this and they're starting to get excited
as well and I guess it's a kind of
feedback loop hmm but I can say that
just in the last three years we've had
tons more interest from companies who
come to us as academics and say look can
we jointly work on something with you I
mean if that's really been a sea change
if we went up to companies even five
years ago and said how about investing
in some research they would say well
we're aware of this but it's over our
horizon yeah but now you know now we're
almost having to fight them off was it
was there a certain you know basic
research or maybe an experiment that
made people realize like oh this might
be the time yeah yeah that there is that
and so I'm a theorist you really should
put that up front they don't let me in
the lab except when they've tied it
everything away because I my elbows tend
to set them back a couple of weeks but
in the lab researchers have been trying
to get better and better control of
quantum systems they're difficult to
control so where I'm you're probably
familiar with the word qubit which is
quantum bits which is of course the
building block of quantum technology
instead of bits but unlike bits which
are wonderfully stable and you know with
the right technology we'll just sit in
the zero or one for a long period of
time even years qubits are horribly
unstable they're constantly trying to
just become regular bits which means
they the usual word is collapsed to one
option or the other you know they we
talk about a quantum superposition a
state that's zero and one at the same
time and we can talk
bit more about that means but the point
is it's fragile qubits don't in a sense
want to be in 0 & 1 at the same time or
rather their environment doesn't want
them to they are constantly trying to
collapse they're constantly going wrong
but also when we try and control them
it's very difficult to control them
precisely so it's all about how good is
your control of the quantum world and I
can't resist at this point just
mentioning we're here in Oxford the
Oxford iron trappers we might talk more
about what that is have the joint world
record for the highest level of control
of any quantum system of any kind okay
and the really tough thing is to say how
well can you control two qubits if you
think about it if you want to make a
computer it's not enough to just control
individual entities because if they
don't talk to each other you can't have
a process an algorithm all you've got is
some kind of recording system right so
if you could go and set the state of a
bunch of individual qubits and then
later come back and have a look at them
you've got a memory mm-hm but if you can
make one qubit control another qubit
you've got an operation an element of an
algorithm gotcha that's that really
that's the hardest thing almost always
because you know it's the most fancy
thing now we we use the word fidelity
which means how well are you doing in
terms of getting your control and the
oxford guys their record is 99.9 a
little bit percent fidelity even the one
part in a thousand fidelity over a
period period of time yeah right so
that's the fidelity that it takes to do
one specific operation so for example I
got two qubits I always use my fingers
because I think of them as little arrows
I have two qubits I tell this guy to
flip only if this guy is let's say in
state one yeah but not if it's in state
zero yep okay so that's a that's a story
about two qubits which should just
happen ideally you tell them to do that
they do it exactly like you told them to
and you move on in practice they won't
do exactly what you told them to because
these things are very hard to control so
99.9 percent is the chances essentially
that they will do what they're told and
if not then they'll do something round
okay you can think of it that way now
that sounds like a lot
right 99.9% seems like a good score in
any context yeah but compared to
conventional technologies where that
number what might be something like up
one minus 10 to the minus 15
you know it's insanely good in
conventional technologies that's why
your software doesn't just crash all the
time on your laptop right so whilst that
number sounds good it's actually still
very challenging imagine you're building
an algorithm hmm you're going to have to
have a lot of these operations right a
lot of times one qubit will talk to
another qubit in the course of doing
some calculation if one in a thousand
times
it just goes wrong and yields nonsense
then if you've got more than a thousand
or so operations and you will have then
something's gonna go wrong
you know you're gonna get a error in
your quantum program and unless you've
been very smart about how you design it
that's just gonna make the answer come
out nonsense so that's that's the kind
of problem we face for all these years
and when I say we I mean the actual guys
in the lab right I've just been at the
whiteboard saying come on guys why isn't
it working yet so we're - it's a briefly
tangent on this yeah how long have you
been theorizing about quantum computers
well the field has been theorizing in
detail about quantum computers since the
early or mid 80s okay I'm a little bit
more recent than that right so as David
Deutsch is thank any sir okay and then
in the 90s we okay so initially people
thought this problem of control was
going to be perhaps a deal breaker the
thing is you see if you're running a
quantum algorithm okay so if you're
running a conventional algorithm you can
at any time check the state of your
machine is there I'm gonna have a look
at my ones and zeros see if they look
about right if you do that with a
quantum computer because of this idea of
superposition being in many states at
once if it's not yet ready to give you
the readout answer but you just want to
check to see if it looks like it's on
track or if it's gone wrong you're going
to destroy the state of the computer you
know prematurely the act of looking for
errors naively it would seem that it's
going to actually destroy the state of
the machine right so how can I keep on
track if I'm not allowed to see it's a
bit like trying to navigate with a
blindfold and you've been told a bunch
of landmarks but you can't see them
right
until you get to the end so people
thought including some really
substantial thinkers like Ralph Lander
thought that that might be a
deal-breaker the fact that you can't
check for errors but they are going to
be happening who would mean that for
anything except the simplest toy
calculation you can't really get where
you're going to and in the 90s was when
people including anestine who's here but
also Peter Shaw who's famous for one of
the big algorithms figured out the
solution to this which it sounds almost
like a philosophical paradox right I
want to be able to check and fix errors
as I run a process complicated long
process but if I look for errors or if I
ask the information whether it's in a
good state I will destroy it right that
seems like a right so the answer is what
you do is you use several qubits even a
large number of them to store one what
we call logical qubit ok is this the
same thing that well it's a grander
version of the same thing that happens
in conventional technology there if you
know you're going to store a lot of
information and there may be some errors
because you're storing you know vast
amounts you may use an error correcting
an error detecting code which means you
dedicate some of your bits to being
watchdogs on the others okay now the
quantum version of that is much tougher
to work out but it's the same basic idea
so we use a bunch of physical qubits
which might be individual items or
superconducting loops many different
exciting hardware options but whatever
they are use a bunch of them to store
one logical qubit yep and you do it in
such a way that if one of those physical
qubits goes wrong you will be able to
fix that one guy by using the
information that's stored in the others
essentially so you've spread out your
burden of representing the qubit over a
bunch of guys and collectively they're
more robust than they would be
individually but you're still not
allowed to just look at them directly so
the real trick was to say well look
we'll have another bunch of qubits we'll
bring them in every so often they'll
just be in some say zero state okay they
have nothing
so they come in neutral they come in
neutral right and then we do a
we stopped the main calculation if you
want to think of it this way we pause
the main computation okay without
observing without observing very crucial
and then we bring in these extra guys
and we have a little special calculation
really a special computation which is
just to look for errors so a computation
takes place between the the new guys who
are just in a reference state and the
guys you actually want to check and what
you basically do is a calculation where
the question is there an error or not is
now stored on the extra guys and they
know nothing else they don't know what
the main information is they just know
has there been an error that's the trick
now you can actually have a look at the
extra guys hopefully they'll say there's
no error good to go if they say there
was an error they'll also tell you which
guy was the problem and you can fix that
guy without looking at him okay through
algorithm through the algorithm if you
like or it may be that when you measure
those extra guys they basically say okay
I don't know what the information stored
on the main qubits is because I'm not
supposed to know that yeah but I can
tell you that qubit number three has has
been flipped I don't even know what
state qubit number three years but he
has it has been flipped right great
that's what the extra guys tell you
sorry this sounds a bit technical but it
is a huge breakthrough annealed and just
to pause you very quickly so the
information you're passing through like
these are qubits as well right so what
you have is you have your main guys who
are storing some information it may have
an error we're not allowed to look at it
you have the extra guys who come in
they're going to be part of the checking
process and then we just talk between
them doing a little calculation little
computation between them using these two
qubit gates that I was talking about
so again errors might happen even during
that process so we have to be very we
have to think of all possible bad things
that could happen and make sure that
none of them are a deal breaker but
basically this trick of not looking for
errors where they are but looking to one
side because you've basically done a
separate little calculation that now in
the what we call ancilla qubits it tells
you just one thing the one thing you do
legitimately need to know which is is
there an error if so where is the error
so that was a very simple idea but very
very important it was but measuring the
insular qubits yeah how do you know that
measurement is correct
you don't okay that's a very good
question right so it's like who guards
the guards right I mean I if there was
one thing that you could trust
absolutely right that would be fantastic
for us and we'd be able to simplify all
our designs and solutions right but we
must assume that everything is
untrustworthy some things are worse than
others so measurement of a single qubit
might be a bit more reliable than say
the two qubit gate but they all have a
number on them that says how dodgy they
are and yet what you need to do is come
up with an approach where there's enough
protection that even if say the Med so
you might falsely conclude that there
was an error and there wasn't one
because the measurement went wrong right
then you're fixing an error that didn't
happen right so you basically need to
construct the overall story so that that
event is so rare that you can run your
whole calculation and it probably won't
evaporate so there's ways of checking
the measurements as well so you it's
layers of protection basically which
makes sense wipe our correction and like
the the my Newton s of the error the
likelihood keeping it low is the most
important part that's right so exactly
so so I mentioned this number 99.9 right
I'm sure I said we're very proud of yeah
it's actually very important number
because when you work through these
schemes for protecting information
because anything can go wrong you tend
to what you find is something called
I'll use another technical right now a
threshold and that means that if you're
doing things better than a certain
number you will be able to use the
protection to get rid of the errors the
physical errors as they occur you'll
stay on top of the problem yeah and
you'll be able to run a long calculation
with nothing going wrong at the logical
level so but suppose that every time you
try to do something make a measurement
to make it to qubit gates something like
that you had a let's say 30% chance of
just wrecking it that would be hopeless
because you'd it's like trying to fix a
broken watch wearing boxing gloves or
something right you're you're going to
cause more damage then then you know so
it had slightly more
for my language you might say it's like
entropy can we remove disorder more
efficiently than we're putting in given
that the process of trying to remove it
itself is a little bit noisy and
damaging so you have to make a net
benefit right you have to take out more
trouble that you're putting in then you
can stay in control mm-hmm and added to
this is you're running actual code so
the code might be erroring out as well
there's there's also a whole other
question which is how reliable is the
algorithm itself but all of this is just
is the Machine even doing what I'm
telling it to do right so you have this
this number which the theorists can
derive and I've spent quite a lot of
time deriving it for particular
approaches which is essentially how good
to the lab guys have to get before they
could now with enough funding and
whatever build a big quantum computer
and know that it will stay on track
because they're now so good at doing the
operations that as errors happen they
can take them out of the machine faster
than than they're happening and so that
is the threshold and now the threshold
when these results were first discovered
in the 90s was about 10 parts per
million so I have a mini 9 99.9999 was
the kind of level of precision that you
would have to have in order to control
your quantum computer and take the bad
things out faster than you're putting
them in regardless of the number of
qubits in the system that's yes exactly
so or almost regardless of poni in
enough to be able to run very large
algorithms and be able to do the things
that we dream of for the big for the big
machine it's always the case that if you
have enough qubits and you have a so
basically what happens is the more you
have you have to slightly dedicate more
and more of them to the checking process
but it's it's not too bad in the sense
that if you double size of the machine
you might only need to slightly increase
the number of guys who are checking but
so this number this threshold in the 90s
it was very demanding so in the 90s we
had the theorists saying good news we
can tell you how to build a quantum
computer and it will work and it won't
go off track despite the worries from
let's say the 80s that it would
have to go off track you know that
problem has been solved at Andy's Dean
and Peter Shaw and many other people who
are excited by that yeah bad news the
level of control you need to achieve in
the lab to use these ideas is still very
demanding it's a it's it's modest by
comparison to how classical I'm so
classical computers being everything
that's not have items' compute right
it's modest by comparison to them but
compared to what you guys are achieving
at say in 1990 in the lab it's horribly
challenging in the lab maybe to qubit
gates might have been around the 90%
fidelity mark at that time and yet the
theorists were saying I need you to be
99.999 you know and and that's a gap and
that was a real time for optimism versus
pessimism because how long will it take
a technology to get a hundred or a
thousand times better in its precision
really there were optimists and I was at
that time I was like getting into that I
was just getting interested in there in
the late 90s in this area and hearing
about it and so of course I was a super
optimist at that time as a student you
had like happening right so I was like
I'll probably have in a couple of years
right and then there were pessimists who
had said this gap between what we need
to be able to build but there is say and
what we can build is so wide it's
probably physically impossible that
would be a ten of what you could say
that and no one would be able to prove
you wrong now to come back at last to
your original question why are people
excited now right it's because that gap
has completely closed the theorists as a
community have been doing better
they've been improving their codes and
making the demands more permissive so
now the the threshold is about 99
percent if you've got 90 if things work
correctly in your quantum computer 99
percent of the time that's the turning
point okay you don't want to be at 99
percent because that's also can be seen
as the point of which things become
impossible you want to be better than
that right but 99.9 which is what the
guys here in Oxford can do is 10 times
better than the threshold so let's break
each component down okay so
how do you move to 99% and above being
accepted what changes have to be made
are you different simulations what's
happening on the theory side we have a
family of approaches now called
topological codes and these things one
could say a great deal about them but
practically what's important about them
is the following very simple property
especially something called the higher
surface code which is at the moment the
go-to solution for how we would build a
quantum computer why is it better than
the codes we had in 1995 it's better
because it the architecture of the
computer can be very very simple in fact
it can be as the name 2d surface code
suggests you're allowed to lay out your
qubits just in a grid which is great
news for experiment lists actually
they'd rather lay them out in a line
because that's the if there's eat
something easier than a grid it's a line
right but that's that's that's very
restrictive but a grid is not too bad I
mean conventional technology is laid out
you have you zoom in on chip onto a grid
and when I say you can lay it out that
way what I mean is that each qubit only
needs to talk to the immediately nearby
guys north south east west the the the
code does not require a qubit to be able
to reach out and talk to a guy three
blocks over the early codes would have
required that they would have required
qubits to be able to link two qubits all
over the place and why is that a problem
most of the ideas for quantum computing
actually involve direct physical
interactions in the physics which is
short-range so if you have an idea where
you can lay out your qubits in a grid
that's very that reflects what is
straightforward in the physics for you
to achieve on the other hand if someone
says to you I want you to do something
where this give it needs to talk over
here and then it needs to go and talk
over here you don't have that in the
hardware so what are you gonna do you'll
have to do a bunch of swaps if you've
only got short-range links in the
hardware and you're actually saying I
need this guy to talk to this guy over
here what you gonna have to do more or
less is
swap swap swap stop stop stop stop swap
and now they're next to each other and
they can talk but you did all those
swaps and those are making errors as
well right
so the cost was in permuting around the
information inside the machine but now
along come the topological codes and
they say no dough is fine you don't need
to move stuff around lay everybody out
and a grid everybody can just sit there
and just talk to the immediate next-door
neighbors and that takes away the whole
it takes away a great deal most off the
operations actually because most of the
operations would have been used for swap
swap swap swap just boringly moving
stuff around hmm okay now by the way we
might perhaps up to you talk about
network approaches to quantum computing
which is something I'm super keen on and
they actually do have the ability to
link any qubit to any other qubit which
is still super desirable even though the
topological codes have told us we don't
absolutely need it it's still great to
have but it does expose you to more
errors not if you do it right isn't the
answer okay what what it means is that
it's tougher to figure out how your
hardware is gonna work but if you can
figure that out and we think we have got
it figured out then you can build a
machine where the qubits are able to
link all over the place right and that
is fantastic for I mean it's always
better to have more connectivity it's
always more powerful to have more
connected right and I'd rather than a
chain yeah
rather than just a what we would call
nearest neighbor which means wherever
you've put your qubits you can only
actually talk directly to their
surroundings okay but still the
topological codes showed that that was
enough and that that's an enormous
simplification so that was responsible
primarily from moving from the multiple
nines to the 99% pressure and then in
the lab well the different kinds of
technology and there are a lot of them
and this is one of the things that makes
the field quite confusing for someone
who just just someone who googles
physical you know I sympathize you type
in quite how does quantum computer work
and you get 20 different answers and
it's worse than ever actually just as an
aside because before by five
if you type in how does a quantum
computer work you get different
academics like me talking about our
favorite approach but academics don't
really have hostility to the other
approaches I mean the ones I don't work
on I wish them good luck you know I just
want to see a quantum computer happen
but now because we have a lot of
companies engaged they need to take a
little bit more of a commercial attitude
to it so if they're investing in a
particular approach and you ask them how
is a quantum computer going to work they
won't tell you about the rivals they're
gonna tell you all about their approach
and why that is the solution for sure
well just think about them fundraising
yeah what if I knew to fund you rather
than the other guy exactly I mean I'm
not complaining in the sense that
obviously they must do this right it's a
very brave guy in a company who says
well it first let me tell you why my
rivals are great and then I'll tell you
why I might have something right and you
could take that approach but that's
non-standard so it's more confusing than
ever to try and figure out how a quantum
computer works what it's going to be
made of what the bits are because there
are so many different possible answers
and now many of them are associated with
companies who are really pushing that
and not giving you the big picture for
perfectly sound commercial reasons right
maybe this is silly to go into one in
particular yeah in the lab in Oxford
yeah what kind of quantum computer right
so Oxford is actually one of the biggest
research facilities in the world for
quantum right we've got something like
200 people working on this and so we're
working on a bunch of different stuff of
course we've got a division between
theorists and experimentalists yeah but
among the experimentalist where we're
not betting everything on one horse
we're taking a bunch of different
approaches but the one that I mentioned
that we have the world record for the
best control is this thing called an ion
trap which sounds very technical it's
really a very simple idea
our qubits are individual atoms an atom
is really nature's natural quantum
system it's the system that people were
thinking about when they actually began
to understand quantum physics so an atom
can make a great qubit the problem with
atoms like the atoms I'm made of is that
they're connected to other atoms and on
and on and on and so you can't have a
particular single atom being a quantum
state without it immediately
connecting to the atoms around it so you
what you would need to do to make a
quantum computer out of atoms is figure
out how to keep them isolated a bit like
the famous Schrodinger's cat in its box
right I need to isolate so we should
explain that medical as well yeah yeah
all right so sometimes I get told off
for mentioning a Schrodinger's cat and
for people it's probably the one thing
they've heard of but so in the early
days of quantum physics Einstein which I
probably people know Schrodinger who was
one of the fathers of the quantum
creating field were discussing in
letters they were exchanging how weird
quantum theory is and whether they could
get behind it as a sort of explanation
of the world and they were struggling
with this idea of superposition which
means a thing can be in two states at
once now when you're talking about
something as far from everyday
experience as an atom maybe it doesn't
sound too bad right because we don't
we're not used to looking at atoms
anyway so if I tell you an atom can be
in two states at lunch and I well that's
weird or whatever so what they came up
with was a thought experiment which it's
important always to emphasize no one
ever plans to do because it involves
potentially killing a cat and you know
everybody loves cats
right but the idea was the thought
experiment was to say well look
according to physics we could do the
following and how weird is that
right so in the experiment we take the
fact that the quantum world which is
normally thought of as the small-scale
of photons and atoms has this weird
property of things happening on both
happening and not happening and scale it
up so the idea is you build a box and
the box
perfectly isolates the inside of the box
from the rest of the universe which
means nothing in the rest of the
universe including you can measure
what's going on in the box its own
little sub universe once the box lid is
closed
what are you put in the box there's a
few variations of this but the version I
like to say because it's more exciting
is that you put a bomb in there okay and
you put a cat in there and the question
is will the bomb go off and kill the cat
or not when the box is shut but it's an
unusual bomb because it doesn't just
have a timer or something it is
connected to some kind of quantum
measurement so it could be for example
whether or not a particular atom decays
so atoms that are radioactive can decay
from one to another and that is a
quantum event that may or may not happen
and in fact if unobserved we would say
it has and hasn't happened that was the
original example but actually it could
be anything we could put in there one
qubit of a quantum computer if we wanted
to make it in more a contemporary
language and we will say I'll put the
qubit in a superposition of 0 and 1 and
then after exactly one minute inside the
box a little measuring device is going
to go and look at that qubit okay and
the qubit will either be 0 or 1 but now
I shut the box I seal it off and I just
wait five minutes right so after one
minute the measuring device looked at
the atom and if it saw state 1 it
activated the bomb and if it saw sate
state 0 it did not activate the bomb
mm-hmm stop and then at that point it's
disarmed if it was also now what quantum
theory would tell you is that at that
moment that the measuring device looked
at the atom what happened was the
superposition that the atom was in a 0
plus 1 it's in a sense spread to the
measuring device so now you've got the
measuring device saw state zero in a
superposition with the measuring device
saw state 1 but the measuring device is
connected to the bomb right so in the
very next instant you have a
superposition of the measuring device
saw state 0 and the bomb didn't go off
and the cat's just bored in the box
right and the measuring device or state
1 activated the bomb it blew up and the
cat is yeah pieces get too graphic about
them so it's a scaling up thought
experiment and it's saying look now
after one minute and we'll leave the box
shut for five minutes so for the
following four minutes inside the box
it's not that one or the other has
happened and we just don't know that
would be the sort of classical
explanation right it's it's that both
those things have happened they are in
superposition with each other and that
is at an actual state of the universe
distinct from being one or the other or
it's one or the other and we don't know
yeah literally both those things are the
case or inside the box and then of
course
you open the box that's a measurement
act from the rest of the universe on to
the little sub universe and now it will
be one thing or the other or depending
by the way on how you interpret the
grand scheme of things you could say the
whole universe goes into a superposition
as soon as the cat is dead than the
mechanism so that was designed to
highlight how weird quantum theories but
there's nothing we would never attempt
that experiment and I suppose if you are
going to do it you would do it with
something other than a like a yeah the
point is to make the microscopic world
where weirdness maybe we can kind of
mentally brush it aside and say yeah
whatever small things are weird right
but there's nothing keeping it small
except the technological challenge of
doing stuff like what I just described
and in a way a quantum computer itself
is a useful and humane version of a
Schrodinger cat experiment because we
imagine having a huge number of
components that are all in not just two
states but in multiple possible States
simultaneously right and we expect to be
able to use that for useful things and
we mustn't open the box as in measure
the qubits prematurely right into how
does that relate to using an atom as
acute right exactly so we want the atom
to be like the cat we want it to be able
to be in a superposition of dead and
lives your own one and maybe you won't
have a bunch of them mm-hmm but we need
to keep them our atoms totally isolated
from the rest of the world just like if
we if are in our Schrodinger Kappa tree
if the box was a bit leaky if you're
like me I just I can't I'm just gonna
keep one eye on it it spoils that the
experiment you know if you're measuring
it one thing or the other will happen we
will not have the superposition yeah
so we need to take our atoms and isolate
them from the rest of the world and
here's how we do it when I say we you
know I'm being very I don't do it they
do it so you first off you wanna have a
vacuum because you don't want your atoms
talking to the rest of the stuff that
the world is made of right so you have
something called a vacuum chamber which
is literally a box which is very tightly
sealed and has some special sort of
ports in it that allow you to for
example pump that atmosphere out of it
and so that's your starting point is a
vacuum chamber
that array is a little bit exotic
compared to conventional computers
because they don't need to have a vacuum
but the good news is that vacuums aren't
particularly hard of all the various
exotic things that we need when we are
thinking about building quantum
computers sometimes it's super low
temperatures as always challenges a
vacuum is actually reasonably mundane in
fact in the early days of computing we
had vacuum tubes we need better vacuums
than that but but we can have better
vacuum so first you have your box
literally a box and you make sure that
there's it's a vacuum in there except
for of course the components of your
technology right so ion trap what does
it mean an ion is just an atom that has
had one electron flicked off of it and
this means so now you're thinking of
your item you've got the core of your
atom and then you've got the electrons
whizzing around it and the whole thing
has is electrically neutral in that
there is many electrons as there are
protons and so it doesn't do anything
special with electric fields it's just
it you know it has no has no net
electric charge but so what you do is
you deliberately flick off one of the
electrons so now your atom which might
be for example for the guys here a
calcium atom has one too few electrons
hmm and what that means is that now it's
it has a net positive charge which means
you can push and pull it around with
electric fuels you can make it come over
here or push just push it away so you
don't you can actually manipulate the
atom hold it push it pull it without
touching it with anything other words
it's floating in the vacuum you can open
it in yellow and you can shoot and pull
it because you don't want it just
bouncing around inside a vacuum chamber
we want it to be in the mid part of our
technology right so an ion is just an
atom that has had one or for us just one
electron flicked off so that now it has
a charge so that now we have a kind of
handle on it right so what do you do
next you have a chip which looks to the
naked eye until you really study it a
bit like any conventional microchip and
the chip has metal elements on the top
of it often gold and those are designed
to just create electric fields so you
charge them up and now they have an
electric field around them and they push
and pull and push and pull
your ion to keep it in one place not
touching the chip but essentially
floating above the chip so here you've
got your vacuum chamber inside it you've
got your ion trap chip which is just a
bunch of little metal elements dirt
cheap dirty actually very expensive
because what they do is they they they
design a particular trap layout and then
they have to get it manufactured write
it in terms of its components it's just
some bits of metal on a sir it's much
much much more basic than say a silicon
chip so the ion trap is chip itself is
nothing special and the atoms are just
atoms but you've now trapped the atoms
in the form of ions because this gives
us the ability to have a grip on them
floating in the middle of a high quality
vacuum not touching anything and inside
the box so now that's a beautifully
isolated system and what you can do is
you can have several atoms you can
essentially have a gap and there's
another one and another one and another
one and then the first thing that you
find or something exciting that you find
is that a quantum superposition will now
last a very long time compared to almost
any other way of doing things so for the
superconducting qubits that many
researchers are excited and we do to
work on that here in Oxford as well the
decay time the amount of time that can
go by before the wonderful zero one
superposition just degrades is the
tiniest fraction of a second of the
order down to a microsecond something
like that for us the guys over the road
have done 50 seconds without let's say
any particularly advanced or special
tricks and it's all ten minutes is also
achievable by another by another lab
using some extra tricks but 50 seconds
which is a proper amount of time might
take me longer than that to explain it
but it's a you know that's how long
without any intervention without any
special tricks and techniques to keep
things alive
you just put just I mean yes thank you
keep being conscious of how I'm being
dismissive of some super called room
temperature so this is at room
temperature okay so you take your ion
you use a laser actually to put it into
a zero and
superposition and then you come back and
you see if it's still in the
superposition you put it in and later
and one way you can do that is you can
reverse the operat so you can use the
canceling laser pulse the opposite
effect of the one you just did and so
you take your zero your zero state and
make it zero plus one and then you come
back and you do exactly the reverse
process and if nothing has changed that
should take you back to state zero but
if the thing is degraded then who knows
you'll be in some random state so you
can come back 50 seconds later and have
a good chance that it's the you know
that indeed you get back to the initial
state which means nothing went wrong for
50 seconds and if 50 seconds isn't
enough for you there are some techniques
which the Chinese group has pianned
pioneered where you can push that out of
ten minutes but the thing is that 50
seconds is enough because in that time
you could have done a huge number of
little processing operations low-level
processing operations inside the machine
you could have got tons of work done in
those 50 seconds because you can do gate
operations on the order of maybe
hundreds of microseconds you could get a
vast amount of stuff done or in fact a
fraction of that now so you can get vast
amount done in the time what's called
the decoherence time which is the
lifetime of your qubit so in the
Schrodinger cat picture the cat would
actually never not stay alive and dead
for permanently because in any real
experiment their box would always be a
little bit leaky of leaky for
information so after some amount of time
which might be you know a minute or or a
year the cat would actually indeed be in
one state or the other and so that we
could call that the decoherence time
it's the case for all quantum approaches
as well and one of the big measures for
how well you're doing is what should a
coherence time are decoherence time is
excellent because our system is
incredibly well isolated from the rest
of the world and so are we swapping in
new qubits every time they're like after
50 seconds throw in another one and then
right so 50 seconds is a long time but
it's not forever
so yeah you two options of this one do a
calculation that
the start of the calculation to the end
is fair bit shorter than 50 seconds that
means everything will just behave as it
should and if well before 50 seconds
you're anyway measuring the system
getting the answer out now for the first
quantum algorithms that we made you know
the first serious ones that might do
something useful the perhaps we'll see
in the coming year that's probably going
to be the approach just go for it try
and get stuff done however it's not
really the answer for a long-running
calculation that might take hours days
because that's you know you can't
suppress decoherence for that long but
the same techniques we were talking
about before that will generally allow
you to correct errors including errors
that you made because you didn't control
things perfectly we'll also Hoover up
these occasional and in fact if you are
doing let's let's think about it if
you're doing maybe hundreds of thousands
of operations per second and those ones
have a one chance in a thousand of going
wrong then you're making a huge number
of errors per second the fact that after
50 seconds the thing would go wrong
anyway is just a drop in the ocean so if
you're already on top of your game in
terms of controlling that rate of errors
which we know that we can be then that
fifty seconds is no problem it's
actually so much of a weaker effect it's
trivial we don't even bother putting it
into our calculations usually because
you know you're dealing with thousands
of times like it's like a fire hose
compared to a dripping for four set
right so we're dealing with the fire
hose we don't bother putting in the
faucet in literate to be honest with you
the only reason in my calculations I
would put that in for an ion trap
calculation is if the referee told me to
write so robbery of my paper and maybe
didn't a hundred percent understand it
and says this is an exciting paper but I
can't believe that they've left out the
effect of a musical decoherence I'm like
all right so then I politely reply to
say we thank the referee for pointing
out our emission and we have now put
that it right and what that meant was
you know that the effective rate of
errors gone up by the tiniest amount and
you guys are so polite all the diagrams
look exactly the same so iron traps are
a very beautiful system in that they've
taken nature
natural quantum unit and successfully
isolated it or a bunch of them from the
rest of the universe and we the the fact
that they discussed success successfully
isolate them is seen by the fact that
they will last in one of these delicate
quantum states for a long time plus
we've also now learned to control them
and get them to talk to each other to
this very high level so they are
actually the gold standard of qubits
but they aren't the only approach you'll
hear about in fact if you look online
you will hear more about the
superconducting qubits which is the
approach to might the main approach that
Google and IBM and even Intel are taking
so that's a different approach and it
has different strengths and weaknesses
so yeah let's assume let's go with yours
for now because the question I'm curious
about yes so the way you tell it to me
like okay this is working this is good
fair enough like let's assume that um
that's scaling it is the challenge
writing is the challenge so actually
it's been a few years now since these
very nice numbers were obtained 2014 for
this for this 99.9 percent so why in
2015 have we not already built the
quantum computer if now the theorists
are saying look I've got some blueprints
and designs and we're good we're all
work exactly and the lab guys are like
well I good news we've actually cracked
that number and is like boom let's go
yeah right well it is the problem of
scaling so it's one thing to have put a
small number of qubits in a box in the
lab and worked on it for a month and
then on a really successful Tuesday
afternoon it you get beautiful data out
to prove it or works and then you get a
paper that's how science it'll sort
progresses it's a gap between that and
figuring out a how would you make that
work not on a lucky Tuesday afternoon
but every single time in a robust way so
that's a kind of an engineering problem
really it's it's taking away the the
things the uncertainties that were
basically not making the experiment work
on Monday but on Tuesday it did right
that's just a development process but
moreover it's saying how can I go from
having two or three of these guys
behaving themselves
having like thousands of these guys
that's the scaling problem everyone is
focusing all their attention on the
scaling problem now the first
interesting number is actually about 50
cubits Y so here I have to say a phrase
that it's not my favorite phrase okay
quantum Supremacy case sounds a bit
racist or something
it is quantum supremacy also sounds like
the end of the road for everything that
isn't quantum well it sounds like AGI
right oh yeah it's all over we've got
friends we're done you don't have a job
quantum supremacy is in that sense a
rather an hyped up phrase but it refers
to something that is very exciting and
that is we hope about to happen so
here's my question for you how big does
my quantum computer have to be before it
could potentially be useful right well
how could we even answer that one way is
this we could say my ordinary computer
especially if it's a supercomputer can
pretend to be a quantum computer
we know the laws of physics that are
governing the quantum system we know the
equations we can't put them digitize
them and put them into software on a
conventional computer and then we can
say to the conventional computer ok you
are now simulating or emulating if you
like a quantum computer and if I set my
quantum computer going and did this
algorithm what would I see now for one
qubit that's easy and actually one qubit
we could do it on the whiteboard
maybe we just just think about what
happens with 1 or 2 for let's say 15
cubits I could write an app it's not in
my pocket I could write an app for my
iPhone that would simulate a quantum
computer that has perhaps 15 cubits ok
easily for 30 29 cubits I would need a
very expensive laptop or a nice laptop
and I would be able to use that machine
to pretend to be a quantum computer with
29 or 30 cubits if I have access to some
of the world's largest supercomputers I
could push it to perhaps forty five
that's been done or a little higher in
term
of the number of qubits now what I mean
by this is I don't want to make any
approximations I don't want to like make
it a bit like a quantum computer
I want the conventional computer to
exactly replicate what a real quantum
computer would do full the full monty if
that's what I want I with enormous
expense like renting time on a top 10
supercomputer I could push into the high
40s in the number of qubits but the
thing is every time I add one more qubit
I double more than slightly more than
double actually the difficulty of the
task and in fact I double the amount of
memory I would need so 45 qubits
required naught point 5 is sort of my
work this is own workouts where in the
community it required for no point five
half a petabyte
of day of RAM radically a bit of a
traditional yeah in your supercomputer
age would be distributed over about x
axis now if you wanted 46 you need a
petabyte if you wanted for seven you
need two petabytes ok 47 is that not
that much more interesting than 45 that
you would build a machine four times as
big right yes it's this exponential
increase which is exactly what we expect
because a quantum computer is supposed
to be exponentially more powerful yeah
than a conventional computer or for
certain tasks and so it's no surprise
that when we try to get our conventional
computer to pretend to be a quantum
computer right we can we can get so far
but we we're on this incredibly
punishing curve yeah so quantum
supremacy is a word that's used
sometimes people say quantum advantage
or so that's there is actually a phrase
which I would love to advocate but I
can't with a straight face which would
be quantum in imitability because no one
can say I even have to think spelling
it's the right it's things and it just
sounds too technical and boring but
that's what's really happening because
once let's say 50 cubits sure you could
with an enormous effort build a
conventional computer that can simulate
50 right right but that would need a
large proportion don't be like her I'm a
bigger bigger than the current
supercomputers right and why would you
because then you still wouldn't be able
to do 51 right yeah
so that point at which it just becomes
ridiculous to Bob
trying to match the power of the quantum
computer that turning-point is referred
to as quantum supremacy or you might say
quantum inevitability because you
literally can't imitate yet the quantum
computer with any sensible sane amount
of classical computing power and so what
that means is that there's no point if
you think you've got a clever idea for
what to use a quantum computer for and
that's gonna change the world if your
idea involves much less than 50 cubits
you're wrong because you may have a very
nice idea but what we would do is we
would just make that into a program that
runs on a conventional computer right
and you could just have it you don't
need to have a quantum computer so once
you're above 50 cubits let's say 64
because that's a nice binary number and
it's much more than 50 so there's no way
you'll be simulating completely a 64
qubit quantum computer or any kind of
classical hardware so you can make that
machine it has the potential to do
things that we can't do by any other
means now something you should I should
immediately mention at this point is we
don't actually know anything the
theorists have not worked out anything
that a 64 cubic quantum computer can do
that's super useful okay including like
breaking crap codes and stuff like that
which is useful if you're the NSA or
whatever cherem is breaking codes is in
the category of things that needs at
least thousands of qubits but because
it's a big tough long-running task it
also needs this whole error correction
thing to be going on and that boosts the
size of it because once you say oh wait
I need error correction then you have to
do this thing we talked about where each
logical qubit is actually a bunch of
physical qubits and for a really long
Angermann it might need to be a lot of
them so you'll be from thousands into
millions of qubits to do the code
breaking stuff so actually we've got
this enormous gap between the point at
which quantum computers could be useful
for something which is 50 and the point
of which they're definitely useful for a
whole bunch of stuff that we've worked
out on paper which is more like a
million qubits right so fifty to a
million that's a bit pretty big gap
and we and we need there to be stuff in
that gap because otherwise that the
thing I like to say is it's a bit like
showing an iPhone to a guy from 1965
right you're like good news the stuff
you're working on these big clunky
computers are gonna give us this it's
gonna happen right in the first poet
anyway so we're all gonna have these
amazing machines right right so the guy
it might be super inspired by that might
jump out of bed in the morning thinking
yeah okay and I'm part of this epic
quest right but when that guy goes to
their boss and tries to get funding for
1966's right it's no good to say in 2018
there's gonna be these are awesome
players right so that's our problem for
quantum computing as well what we've
worked out on paper is stuff that needs
pretty big computers and we don't know
how long it would take to get there what
you know maybe hopefully not decades but
you can take there in more than a decade
to get to the point where we have
millions of well behaved qubits on the
other hand what we believe is about to
happen in the coming year is that people
will start to bring out qubits Nursery
quantum devices that are apt or just a
limit over the quantum supremacy
threshold this number a lot of people
are racing to deliver 50 cubits because
it's this kind of magic number
so those machines however won't as far
as we know be immediately useful for
stuff that people really want to do
we'll be able to test out their
quantumness and show them off with a
whole bunch of ideas but it won't break
codes it won't what are some of the
other things people are excited about
are breaking codes is often mentioned
and it isn't a very positive application
by the way breaking it codes but it is
very interesting because the difficulty
of breaking codes is so well-established
and therefore if a new machine comes
along and can do it the machine must
have something special about it that the
old ones didn't have right that's why
it's so exciting as I sort of a showcase
but as a counterpoint of that the code
could also be created by a quantum
computer correct that's true funded okay
that's true so that it quantum giveth
and taketh away but Iran taketh away and
giveth because a quantum computer would
crack the codes that we rely on today on
a classical computer yes but we can also
divide design communication systems that
are protected by quantum physics where
basically an E
strata who tries to see what the
communication is would cause unnecessary
disturbance like the uncertainty
principle it's necessary if you measure
a quantum system to disturb it and that
would be detected so quantum can also
offer you it's almost like a Salesman
you're like it fab use all your current
technology for security is you know
become gonna become if you good news
brochure right but um yeah so the the
things we are excited about that quantum
computers will one day to code-breaking
not most exciting but a very important
proof of the power of the machines but
what people are really more excited
about quantum enabled discovery is a
phrase which basically means hmm in
science and also in industrial rd like
drug discovery and so on there's an
enormous amount of trial and error
because it's not possible to use
software to predict what what's going to
happen so we can't predict what would
make a great superconductor and in that
way just go uh sell or I will go make
that that will be an amazing
super-galactic
trial and error trial and error we we're
not very good yet at predicting how to
synthesize complex molecules so chemists
who have an enormous amount of intuition
and years of experience just go and try
it and they occasionally get a break
through trial and error a trial and
error if we could have a far more
powerful machine for predicting the
behavior of these things we could take
the trial and error out imagine you're a
chemist you want to synthesize this big
fancy molecule because you believe that
it will help with Alzheimer's or
something like that it's exactly the
right molecular shape instead of trial
and error you just set that task to your
quantum computer in the morning the
quantum computer come back and a quantum
computer says well I had to think about
it if you do this and then this and then
this and then this with this chemical
and this chemical brain will synthesize
that thing right that would supercharge
the rate of progress that we have in
various areas so molecular synthesis in
materials design and discovery and could
give us perhaps it's high P for me to
say it but almost a golden age of
rapidly discovering new materials new
chemicals new drugs so that would be
very in this exists in a how many qubits
are we talking right here exactly so the
Skee the ideas that the theorists have
worked out thoroughly already yeah would
again seem to need millions of cubits
but there's hope that some of these
tasks may actually work with far fewer
cubits and in particular some of these
tasks may not need the error correction
thing and the error correction thing is
great as a as a principle but it
requires you to make the quantum
computer much bigger because you have
the logical qubits which turn into a
bunch of physical qubit if you don't
need that if you can just use the direct
atoms ions of your computer as the
logical qubits then you can maybe get
stuff done with one hundred qubits or a
couple of hundred qubits probably a bit
more than 50 but you know your app that
could be an application that sits near
to the the kind of end of the chasm you
know 50 to a million that's this big gap
yeah we're at the 50 end is there a
stepping stone a very interesting
stepping stone which would be the
ability to simulate chemistry and
material system that's actually quite
near our end of the chasm that would be
super exciting right and does this
relate back to your network design
before cuz I you planted the seed no I
did like to see so yeah I kind of want
to harvest it so yeah if we're now
saying look I understand this fault
tolerance is threshold this all that's
exciting stuff but that stuff lives at
the other side of the chasm that's what
you do with your million cubic quantum
computer to make yourself to run forever
yeah but now let's focus on what we
might get done in the next two or three
years you know what are these first
machines these these embryonic or
adolescent quantum computers going to be
able to do now we come back to
connectivity if I have to swap my qubits
ten times or a hundred times before it
gets next to the guy it now needs to
talk to that's very debilitating because
now I will pick up loads of error on the
way over there and my whole algorithm
will be very burdened with error and we
aren't using these clever error
correction techniques we can't afford it
in terms of the number of qubits we've
only got 200 right by the way two
hundred qubits I mean 50 is where we
want to be in the coming year yeah
hopefully that will become 200 fairly
enjoy the baseline where we at right now
that's right so where we're at right now
is that various labs around the world
can give you 20 cubits ok-ish 10 to 20
what's been an
and trailered sometimes announced
sometimes kind of unofficially in there
by some of the big companies is that
they're working on a 50 qubit machine
okay because that's the obvious you know
goal right it's the get to 50 and that's
typically in a grid that's like a seven
by seven that would give you 49 a grid
of qubits but that those plans those
designs our nearest neighbor ones which
means if you want the guy in one corner
to talk to the other if you swap stop
stop stop stop stop stop stop so you'll
get a lot of error in there so we're in
the regime of like tens of qubits trying
to push 250 now the network approach
we're taking is a very different
philosophy the number of qubits we have
for a long time has just been a handful
of them like five and we're not trying
to scale that up and why not because
five is far too few to do anything
useful what we're trying to do is have
five inside a box that behave really
well and make a beautiful little useless
but beautiful little quantum computer
and then to understand how to link that
box to another box with an optical link
and the idea is that if you can crack
that if you can have a small quantum
computer and make it link to another
small quantum computer that's sitting
right next to it and if you've mastered
that then nothing stops you except your
checkbook I guess from making loads of
them and linking them up that's our
approach to scalability it's not to have
the qubits directly talking to each
other and then you say well I've done 20
let's see if I can do 50 that was super
hard let me shoot for 64 we're adding
more and more complicated I'm having to
control more and more parameters it's a
nightmare which is the way it's been up
to now anyway
instead we're saying look let's just get
really good at making a small module of
fixed size and learn how to plug to
connect to modules so they can talk to
each other so it's it's a quantum
computer that's divided into little
pieces and each piece is independent and
it's pretty much plug and play in the
sense that you just if you if you had 50
of these modules then that would be a
very powerful machine if you manufacture
another 10 you just plug them in and now
it's an even more powerful machine and
in this this optical link doesn't have
the same degree of disturbance that's a
very good question
so how does the optical link work it the
optical link
does indeed have a lower quality to it
than the internal operations which will
be super good yeah at this ninety nine
point nine that we've already gray okay
um so the the reason people don't do
this because it sounds like a great
solution like why don't everybody make a
little quantum computers and link them
up is the answer right it is the answer
but there is a problem which is that the
links up that they there's nothing in
the physics that means the links can't
be beautiful and very clean and very
high quality but in terms of the
experiments that have been achieved so
far the links are not great so you might
have inside your box one part in a
thousand is your error rate but for the
links one part in ten might be your
error rate so then you think well that's
no good
because if I'm joining up these
beautiful little components with crappy
connections the whole machine is
actually going to be crappy not
beautiful right so but there's an answer
to that which is very much like what you
would do in conventional technology
which is that you use the link several
times and you that by using it several
times you can effectively get one better
quality communication out of it right so
your phone I keep reaching for my faves
on here but yeah your phone if it's on
the edge of your if it's in one bar of
your wireless that's at the point where
it's it's very iffy whether it can
connect or not but when you load a
webpage it loads more slowly but it
still loads perfectly it's not like the
images are full of static no yeah and
that's because your phone can keep
requesting it uses a code to protect the
information it can also request so it
can say I didn't get that send it to me
again
right so we know now how to use the same
kind of idea in the quantum setting to
say I've got a bit of a crappy link
between what we might call the Alice
module and the Bob we love Alice and Bob
in the quantum field a and B right fair
enough you must okay so you're sending
packets the whole thing like that right
I'm being a little bit loose so the
actual thing we do is something called
entanglement which is we haven't
discussed but that's the other big most
people have heard or any quantum
involves something called entanglement
right yeah Einstein called spooky and
blah blah blah the test of whether your
quantum computer can really be broken
into little modules and wired up one way
to ask that question precisely is to say
can you achieve good quality
entanglements between two modules
that would be the proof that they are
actually part of the same quantum state
part of the same quantum machine and if
you cannot get entanglement between the
Alice module and the Bob module then
your machine will forever really just be
a bunch of separate units that aren't
teaming up to create one quantum state
one quantum calculation so you could say
then all right I've got a link between
my two boxes let's think about that link
what quality of entanglement can it
create between the Alice ion trap on the
Bob one and I might say well not very
good only ninety percent and then you're
like well that's not very good that's
not good enough for me I'm gonna so what
we actually do is we create a couple of
qubits that are entangled at ninety
percent not very good and we store them
and remember we can store stuff
practically forever
oh is that well 50 seconds but that
range and then we create another what we
would call another technical phrase at a
bell pair which means two guys that are
entangled with each other and again
there'll be a 90 percent quality there
will be you know not good not hot not as
high as we want but now we've got two
why would school crappy Bell Pez and
what we know how to do is to sacrifice
one in order to boost the quality of the
other so it's a little bit I mean this
is too loose an analogy but it's a
little bit like if if you someone's
trying to talk to you and it's a little
bit
staticky if you hear it once you're not
sure but if you hear it twice even
though it's staticky both times you're
able to infer more reliably what that
what that information was so that's a
very loose analogy but basically we take
two poor quality communication channel
uses and we make it into one good one
hmm and that is the prop that is the
solution to that problem as long as your
boxes have a very good memory they do
have a very good memory as long as they
have very good quality internal
operations which they do have then you
can take a poor quality link and boost
it by using it a few times into
effectively a very good quality link as
good actually as the internal operations
so we we actually are planning to build
a machine which will be made out of
modules which each one is a small
quantum computer and by the way so small
that on its own it's not good for
anything okay even as few as five cubits
right
and then we we have modules and we link
them up and when two of these modules
need to talk to each other to become
part of a single unified quantum state
will use our link and our link will need
to be used several times and then
purified or distill this is the phrase
we use in order to make it as if it was
a very beautiful very perfect link and
now these two modules will be connected
in a high fidelity high quality way and
does this perform at the same degree
that say so say your your 10 cubed
quantum computer while you're stitching
them all together
is it performing at the same speed as
one of these 50 cubits yeah and that's
another great question so initially no
okay because the links are individually
they're fast in there could be about
megahertz rate or something like that
but the problem is is a technical
problem a very interesting one that
we're having at the moment is that the
links are optical so what happens is a
particle of light called a photon comes
out of your ion and flies out of your
iron it needs to be caught and put into
a optical fiber and that needs to be
going on at the other end as well the
problem is at the moment most of the
light gets lost it doesn't it comes out
of the ion it just hits the wall of the
chamber or we know how to solve that
problem by essentially building what we
would call a cavity which is a way of
catching and controlling light into the
system and we're working on it but for
the first generation of the technology
that we envisage we won't have that
there's a little bits two steps down the
road so instead we'll have to just deal
with the fact that we that these links
are kind of slow in that you you try to
use the link and nothing happens you try
to use the link and nothing happens you
try and you succeed and then you have to
do that a few times so that slows you
down a lot so the actual rate at which
the clock speed if you like sure of our
modular quantum computer will be limited
by the rate of connection in version one
but for version one we don't really care
how long it takes to run because we'll
be doing small problems that can fit in
fifty or a hundred or two hundred qubits
so they'll be fast anyway and it doesn't
really matter if they take it's not this
is oversimplifying witters doesn't
necessarily matter if the calculation
gets done in ten micro
seconds or or in 10 milliseconds or
indeed in 10 seconds because it's a
small calculation anyway that we're
trying to do so what we envisage is a
first generation of this technology
which so you've drilled right down to it
actually it has interesting properties
versus these 50 these 7x7 grids it's
slower mm-hm but it's higher fidelity
and it's higher connectivity we believe
that it will actually be you would use
them for different things but if I'm
gonna choose one I'm gonna say ours is
the better okay and then as things
mature and you have more and more
modules and you start to take on more
and more challenging problems and it
starts to become frustrating that you're
limited by the link speed then we have
this solution that will basically stop
us wasting over light catch over light
and then we come right up comparably to
the speed of other approaches whilst
still having the very high connectivity
and the free scalability and so on so
what we actually picture is some if you
if you've seen those photos of say a
Google server farm you need these very
big facilities where you've got in you
know look in different directions you've
got these pillars running off into the
distance you can picture something like
that for a single quantum computer if
you want where you have a bunch of
modules yep and they link and you have
the fibers coming up and going you know
in sort of cable guides and coming back
down again and so you build your quantum
computer in a big room but why not rooms
are relatively cheap compared to quantum
computers so it doesn't really matter if
it's big or small it means that the end
user won't directly have a quantum
computer in their phone for any time but
the to be honest there's no approach to
quantum computing that's that's that's
at the same sort of level of maturity as
superconducting qubits or ion traps that
could possibly fit a quantum computer in
your phone but that doesn't matter
because the way you use your phone to do
the more challenging tasks even speech
recognition is typically in the cloud
right we would say in the cloud so as
long as somewhere there's a big fat
quantum computer behaving itself
achieving you know having a low error
rate having the necessary connectivity
being big enough to tackle the tasks
then in principle that can be doing jobs
not just for the scientists and
researchers but if you've been able to
of an application so machine learning
might be one of them that actually
benefits the end user the end user can
also use the quantum computer so we
picture this kind of thing a modular
machine where you have as many modules
as as you need to get the tasks done and
by the way at the moment our module that
the vacuum chamber in the lab is this
kind of size oh really chunky okay not
too bad I saw that photo floating around
someone here won an award right for
their floating oh yeah there are
actually quite pretty because they're
sort of shiny metal and they've got
these cool portcullis things in the side
they look a bit like steampunk
technology so they're about this size
the reason they're that size is because
in the lab you want to be able to get
your hand in there right you don't you
it's human scale technology you know you
want to get screwdrivers in there and so
on
but there's nothing inherent to the
technology that would make them be that
energy they would work a little bit
better if they were miniaturized so you
could shrink that down to a far smaller
little vacuum chamber and that's your
little quantum computer and then you
want 50 or 100 or 200 of those but
that's not so bad you know just lay them
out and so we that'sthat's our picture
is that that's the thing we'd love to
build actually and there is no
fundamental impediment to that actually
so if someone came to us and gave us a
billion dollars we could have a crack at
building that tomorrow but no one has
given us a billion dollars so instead
we're taking a slightly more sort of
traditional academic conservative route
of thrashing out the physics of two of
these guys and then having a think about
how to sort of come up with the next
generation which is a bit better and
then building four and then building 16
and 32 and 64 but there will certainly
be a point and I think actually much
earlier than 32 so it once you've
cracked the physics of even two of these
guys you're good to go in the sense that
you know you can you can just partner
with a company that would manufacture
these things and you can just have your
constitute together and go and in fact
this this network approach is I think
the only one that if you wanted to
Manhattan Project it right or moonshot
is in one of these big projects that
have happened in the past where you have
a goal that's extremely challenging and
you just decide you're going to make it
happen
if you want to do that with a quantum
computer if you said look I I'm
impatient to wait 10 years 15 years for
the big quantum computers to come
I want it to come now
the network approach is the only one
that could potentially deliver that
because we just when we think about
approaches where the qubits are right
next to each other and just make that
structure bigger and bigger and bigger
people are having heroic efforts now to
deliver 7x7 grid but from talking to
those researchers it doesn't seem to me
that they will then immediately know how
to do you know a 10 by 10 grid that will
bring a whole new raft of problems and
levels of control challenge and so on
at some point presumably you do know how
to just keep on scaling with a
relatively modest amount of new
investment but with the modular approach
as soon as you've got two guys that link
really well you can have a million if
you can afford the cost of one times a
million right the serve I mean there is
no difference in tirana on the system
lines change right and so on the
timeline side like are we talking within
a couple years that you guys are gonna
make this happen you think well it
depends on how much interest there is in
actually trying to build the machine
that's potentially useful academics it
left of their own devices will tend to
go hard for the interesting scientific
results but they don't really we don't
really know how to tackle the problem of
building a big facility that's not a
problem for a university professor
I mean or the funny you don't have the
same incentive as a company not exactly
a company would be saying to its
shareholders or investors look here's
our year one his are you two is our year
five milestones and we'll be able to
achieve each stage yeah academics
working in a different way right but
what I will say to you is that certainly
sorting out thoroughly and demonstrating
this idea of two modules which fully
linked together to form a single unit in
practice so you know to the programmer
it's a single quantum computer the
engineer knows that it's been broken
into two pieces with an optical link so
getting that demonstrated is is an
immediate goal for us in the next year
getting authority demonstrated whether
we then go hooray
let's go thousand of them right I would
love to by the way no I would love to do
that yeah there is nothing more exciting
than saying we've cracked it the more
naturally academic route would be to say
okay we've got that now let's get that
cavity thing in now let's do this now
let's do this and
and you know you just keep making the
physics better and more exciting and
more well controlled but I do believe
that once you've got two modules that
talk to each other really well and have
all these lovely properties you are you
you you you have a green light to go
large on that if you want to and yeah it
but it is okay this probably get a bit
boring but it's um it's an interesting
problem all around the quantum computing
field not just for people who want to
build networked machines that you you
think how do you actually get from the
lab to some kind of device you know
that's a problem that people have met in
many different areas
over the years but I think it's
particularly acute for quantum computing
because it is such a difficult to
understand technology it does require
such a lot of detailed know-how it's not
easy to do let's say tech transfer out
of the laboratory into some kind of
commercial setting but it's happening
there are spin-out companies coming from
academics all over the place now as they
start to wrestle with this question of
how can I have a an investor facing
aspect of my research where I can indeed
start to think about these exciting
questions let's build yeah do you think
now is the time just kind of wrapping up
that people are gonna start rolling out
you know like cloud compute or are we
not quite there yet
um I think there are already companies
which aim to do that
I think so too so in that sense we are
there I I think that um I'm excited by
that and yet also a little bit worried
by it because of course when a startup
company especially but even a you know
Titan like IBM when they need to explain
their actions to their investors and
excite their investors and shareholders
and they're going to pitch things in a
very optimistic way that an academic
would normally be more cagey about and
there's that tension that I already see
in the fields between the story that
you'll hear from you know and the worry
is that it will create too much
expectation there will be too many
stories appearing in the Economist and
whatever about how quantum is going to
revolutionize everything I don't know
quantum supremacy as exciting as the
phenomenon that it refers to it is a
little bit I'm afraid
and feeding into that hype because if
you're an investor and you've read a
little bit about this you're like right
I'm going to invest in this company that
will achieve a 50 qubit machine it will
get quantum supremacy and then profit
yeah and there is no no it's one of
those step 1 step 2 step 4 is profit or
whatever yes show those migrate we don't
yet know useful things to do with a
small quantum computer we're furiously
working on that and we haven't talked
about machine learning that's another
sort of interesting possibility that's
being explored to put it simply we
talked about the enabling more rapid
discoveries which is very exciting but
we can't yet prove on paper that a small
machine will be able to do those things
with your ously investigating it so the
risk is that people get too excited they
think things are going to happen in the
next one to two years in terms of not
just the exciting machines coming out
but in terms of actual useful
breakthroughs you know this drug was
developed under yeah one two or three
thousand you know that kind of stuff
within the next couple of years which
might happen but could very easily not
happen and you know the hype machine
starts to feed itself so in artificial
intelligences we were talking about
there's been a couple of AI winters
which the guys now when I heard the
phrase AI winter I assumed it was like
from when Skynet launches all the nukes
right and then we're a sci-fi thing but
our AI winter is just that the field
started to attract loads of attention
their loads of investors and then it
didn't quite deliver fast enough and
then suddenly became toxic to say that
you were working in AI and that was like
nonsense and silly stuff for academics
and but not once but twice right and any
for a couple of years the field
struggles to get funding and then starts
to build up again I mean I know people
working in machine learning now that are
very concerned there's like we want to
be able to continue working machine
learning is now working in the sense
that it's working in facebook it's
giving us self-driving cars and yet
somehow expectations still manages to
run ahead of it right people just can't
stay calm and so it's there's even a
possibility that will happen again for
sure be over invested it might be that
that's just the way things have to
happen but it would be kind of nice as
an academic a slightly more sort of
conservative I want to see more linear
progression so I'd rather that the
quantum computing field did not over
inflate and then collapse and then we
we'll have to really struggle to get
funding for a while and then it can
build up again it would be nice if we
could actually model a hobo who knows
but it is I'm more excited than I've
ever been to see these because we are
now getting on the verge of getting
machines that will behave in ways that
cannot be predicted cannot be simulated
we'll be in the regime where we're
genuinely discovering how the machine
behaves by having one and that's what
we've been dreaming of all these years
and there is also the potential to just
really commit and try and build a big
machine which I would love to do but who
knows the last question and if someone
wants to get involved you know start
working in quantum computing somehow
yeah where do you think they can provide
the most value oh gosh well I mean the
answer to that question is a richer
answer than it was even a couple of
years ago but a couple of years ago the
real answer would be to be honest you
need to be in university as a young
person you need to choose the right
course options and you just need to go
into academia now there's a richer way
set of ways you can get involved still
that's the primary one to be honest
right but there are companies that are
recruiting people with all kinds of
expertise now including for example
software engineers who don't know
anything about quantum but they do know
about writing high-performance software
my work with some such people right
because one of the things we want to do
is push the limit of how well our
conventional computers can pretend to be
quantum computers that's important also
to check that the emerging quantum
computers are really doing what they say
that right right for example if you are
a programmer who would love to get
involved with this there are now
opportunities where you can provide that
part of the puzzle or if you are a
systems engineer who doesn't again have
a huge background in quantum physics but
wants to be part of this process the
good news is people are now trying to
build these complex machines that are
really too much for the laboratory and
are really complex machines that need to
be developed in a separate project and
so we are looking for people who know a
lot about systems integration or these
kind of problems and they don't need to
understand the deep properties of the
quantum aspects of it so you know
getting a vacuum chamber that has a good
optical interface is a set of problems
which enable a quantum computer
but you don't need to understand quantum
superposition and the field is trying to
diversify to include more such people
not just professors whose merit measure
of success is can they get a paper into
science major but people who are
outstanding engineers and programmers
who don't care about getting papers into
nature but do care about meeting you
know their goals and you know satisfying
their contracts essentially so we are
diversifying it is leaving academia or
at least spreading out and so I would
say anyone who has a lot of technical
expertise in these kind of areas or
anyone who's a very good programmer the
doors now open to participate in the
quantum revolution that's great well
thank you so much for your time okay
thank you
it's been fun
you